elle serait la seule candidate à la cour
suprême que dans notre champ pourrait
rencontrer et micro hybride serait la
prochaine juge de la cour suprême des
etats-unis et la plus jeune
cette magistrate de 48 ans une fervente
catholique est la coqueluche des milieux
religieux en 2017 lors de ces audiences
de confirmation de juge à la cour
d'appel
elle explique que ses convictions
religieuses n'influence pas ses
décisions judiciaires je prends ma foi
au sérieux dit-elle mais pas au
détriment de nos yeux de voir comme je
mange un réputé pour ses positions
contre l'avortement pour le droit de
porter des armes
elle n'aura pas réussi à convaincre la
sénatrice démocrate votre religion
prévaut avant tout dit elle vous êtes de
john senio et miccoli barrette et membre
du groupe catholique people13 elle a
également travaillé pour l'ancien juge
conservateur de la cour suprême
antonin scalia s'est entouré de ses sept
enfants que cette juge de la cour
fédérale a répondu aux questions du
comité sénatorial
elle a adopté deux enfants d'haïti et à
un garçon atteint de la trisomie 21
benji mènera ce passionné its benjamins
à des besoins particuliers des allées ça
représente un défi mais je trouve à dire
que c'est de préférer utilisant floing à
plusieurs reprises elle a tenté de
rassurer les sénateurs démocrates de son
impartialité
ce serait inapproprié qu'un juge impose
ses clients religieuse avec cette
nomination six des neuf juges de la cour
suprême auront été nommé par des
républicains dans notre champ pas déjà
affirmé que s'il perd ces élections il
va contester les résultats à la cour
suprême une cour suprême qui risque de
pencher de plus en plus de son côté il y
avait pas de l'eger guise radio-canada
washington